let's go next to Stoney from Indiana
Stoney from Indiana welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
hey David uh how are you I'm doing well
good um yeah so I was just wondering I
know that you kind of sighed on the side
of capitalists and some of the viewers
or more on the leftist side but I wanted
to see your take on crypto specifically
and uh kind of there's been some
legislation from Elizabeth Warren and
things of that nature
um just wanted to see if you're a crypto
bro or kind of where you stand on that
whole side of things yeah so I've got a
couple dozen videos about crypto I
bought Bitcoin and ethereum back in I
believe it was 2016 and
um I've been clear that I have no
emotional attachment to crypto I don't
think crypto is uh going to save the
world I also don't think crypto is
uniquely evil I basically took the
approach back in 2016 this might be a
thing I want to put about three percent
of my assets into it
um crypto Bitcoin and ethereum did
really really well so that three percent
would become six percent and then I
would sell half and then it would become
six percent ganonide cell half and
obviously more recently crypto has
diminished in value and I have
absolutely no prediction about where
it's going Bitcoin could be in five
years at a million dollars or it could
be at zero I have no idea I think it's
very volatile I think it's risky and I
think
um many of the use cases that are cited
aren't really that interesting or
compelling
so I I guess more so to my point it's
behind the I I've never been much of a
crypto person I worked in Finance on uh
in Wall Street and that sort of thing so
um I we kind of stayed away from it
because it seemed like you know a fairy
tale but the more I look into it the
technology seems very fascinating
um the blockchain sort of Technology
seems fascinating in of itself even you
look at the things like George Santos
getting in trouble for the election or
campaign funds that sort of stuff if it
was available on the blockchain that
sort of transparency I think would help
with politicians and knowing what
they're doing with their funds and just
making everything publicly available
through that record so I don't know if
you have anything else to add on that
but that was just kind of my two cents
no I mean listen you you're not wrong I
just don't know that it's that obvious
that the blockchain is the only solution
to like having net not fallen for the
lives of George Santos I just I I'm I'm
not as technologically savvy as one
would need to be for me to definitively
say the blockchain is the solution to
George Santos's lies or there's five
other solutions that are just as good I
don't know yeah I don't think we prevent
like towards Santos because clearly
there's not like proper vetting going on
from the the sort of committees but more
so my point is uh if if all these
transactions
from every politician was available on
the blockchain
um such as how crypto is designed the
same thing with the fraud if there's
fraud in crypto you can trace it all the
way back to its Origins yeah uh because
of the transparency so more so just like
from a corrupt politician perspective
even in Indiana our secretary of state
bought a bunch of stuff was kind of put
his feet to the fire about it and we
still elected him because it's a
Republican state we don't really care so
it's just those sort of things that I
mean from a transparency perspective we
have zero you know trust in our
government when it comes to what they're
using the funds for I think from a
technological perspective it's very
um interesting and
um you know just more ways for us to
trust the government in and of itself I
mean you this thing could be applicable
all the way to the police forces being
forced to yeah you know Stoney I don't
know I think I get it I I just I don't
know that blockchain is what we need for
police accountability vote counting
determining I think that we're starting
to go into like it seems like it can't
it doesn't make sense to me that it's
the solution to everything and that's
where it starts to get a little bit
weird for me but listen um I appreciate
the call and we're going to continue to
follow it
all right thanks David all right Stoney
from Indiana we're going to take the
quickest of breaks and then we'll be
right back and hear from more of you
one of our sponsors is little spoon your
One-Stop shop for healthy easy meals and
snacks for your baby toddler or big kid
delivered right to your door little
spoon has you covered with fresh organic
baby food for every stage they have
toddler and kids meals that even the
picky eaters will love they have
smoothies for on the go and they just
launched a new product called biteables
which are early finger food meals cut
into bite sizes for easy self-feeding
which will make your transition to the
table food a breeze little spoons baby
food is 100 organic and cold pressed for
every eating stage my daughter loves
those for toddlers and big kids little
spoon has the classics like mac and
cheese but they'll sneak things in like
butternut squash and carrots they're all
kid approved and packed with nutrients
and the best part kids meals are under
six dollars each baby food under three
dollars a serving so it's quick easy and
affordable go to littlespoon.com and
you'll get fifty percent off your first
order with the code Pacman 50 off the
link is down below